bonjour je m'appelle Olivia Lan et je suis chercheuse et éducatrice chez IBM Quantum cette vidéo marque le lancement d'une
toute nouvelle série sur la chaîne YouTube de Qiskit et notre plateforme d'apprentissage appelée L'Informatique Quantique en
pratique en bref dans cette série je vais te montrer comment utiliser un ordinateur quantique qui existe en ce moment même à son
plein potentiel il y a des milliards de vidéos déjà sur internet sur les ordinateurs quantiques et leur potentiel futur ou sur les concepts théoriques
derrière le calcul quantique qui sont aussi tout aussi importants vois la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantique
animée par John Watrous par exemple mais dans ce cours nous allons supposer que l'apprenant connaît peut-être un peu plus
que ce que nous avons fait par le passé et nous allons aller très loin techniquement parlant et c'est parce que au cours de l'année passée et au
moment de cet enregistrement c'est 2024 nous avons vu une transition de phase si tu veux vers une nouvelle ère de
calcul les ordinateurs quantiques approchent enfin le point où ils peuvent être utiles même si expérimenter avec des
circuits à petite échelle et des ordinateurs quantiques était nécessaire pour éduquer notre communauté sur comment utiliser ces machines personne ne menait des expériences
qui ne pouvaient pas aussi être réalisées sur des ordinateurs classiques ordinaires mais à partir d'aujourd'hui nous sommes entrés dans une ère de
l'utilité quantique et qu'est-ce que l'utilité tu pourrais demander c'est différent de l'Avantage Quantique qui peut être compris comme le
point auquel les ordinateurs quantiques surpassent les ordinateurs classiques à une tâche significative mais l'utilité signifie
qu'ils peuvent commencer à se concurrencer les uns les autres et c'est la prochaine étape naturelle dans l'évolution
technologique IBM a publié un article qui a montré pour la première fois l'année dernière qu'un ordinateur quantique pouvait être utilisé pour
simuler un modèle physique et se mesurer aux techniques de simulation classique de pointe il a même surpassé les
tentatives de force brute et a permis aux chercheurs d'avoir une nouvelle voie qu'ils peuvent utiliser pour la recherche alors pourquoi tout cela se passe-t-il
maintenant eh bien au cours des derniers mois IBM a rendu largement disponibles des processeurs quantiques de plus de 100 qubits si tu es
déjà un utilisateur tu as peut-être remarqué que nous avons retiré beaucoup de nos processeurs plus petits pour faire place à ces puces plus grandes et nous pensions que c'était vraiment
important de le faire parce que certains nombres de qubits peuvent encore être simulés classiquement sans problème donc il n'y a
pas d'avantage réel à gagner en utilisant ces puces cependant à 100 qubits ce n'est plus le cas ils ne peuvent
pas être simulés classiquement il est aussi important de noter qu'il y a ces choses appelées simulateurs qui
sont essentiellement des programmes informatiques et ils peuvent imiter certains comportements des systèmes quantiques y compris le bruit cependant s'il te plaît
ne manque pas le fait que j'ai dit imiter les simulateurs ne sont pas des ordinateurs quantiques ils ne peuvent pas produire les résultats que
les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent à cette échelle mais ils sont toujours une partie importante de notre flux de tests donc c'était une
réponse très longue à la question en haut de cette diapositive qu'est-ce que l'Informatique Quantique pratique dans ce cours je vais t'apprendre les cas d'utilisation réalistes
potentiels pour le Quantique et les meilleures pratiques pour exécuter et expérimenter sur ces processeurs à plus grande échelle
d'aujourd'hui alors à qui ce cours est-il destiné commençons par faire un calibrage
du niveau au début ce cours est pour tous ceux qui visent à développer de nouvelles applications pour les ordinateurs quantiques veulent
savoir comment faire évoluer leur travail actuel ou apprendre comment utiliser le quantique dans leurs flux de travail existants j'ai précédemment
mentionné que ce cours sera très pratique et nous ne discuterons pas des aspects théoriques autant nous
attendons que tu arrives avec une compréhension de base de ce qu'est le calcul quantique mais si tu n'es pas encore là pas de souci regarde s'il te plaît juste
les premiers épisodes du cours de John Watrous et tu seras prêt nous voulons aussi nous assurer que les gens qui regardent savent
que ce n'est pas juste un cours pour les physiciens ou même les informaticiens ces deux sujets ont vraiment
monopolisé l'Informatique Quantique depuis une décennie environ nous voulons nous assurer que d'autres qui travaillent avec de grandes données ou des
simulations comme les ingénieurs les chimistes et les scientifiques des matériaux savent que ce cours est aussi pour eux en résumé ce
cours est dirigé vers un large public et nous espérons que tu te joindras à nous pour la totalité du cours après avoir terminé ce cours tu
pourras comprendre comment créer et exécuter un travail à l'échelle utilitaire via le runtime de Qiskit y compris l'ensemble du flux de travail
tu pourras comprendre les principaux types de mitigation des erreurs et aussi comprendre les domaines d'application probables à court terme tu pourras aussi
réaliser tous ces algorithmes dans Qiskit et enfin nous attendons que tu puisses comprendre le bruit et comment le gérer
alors commençons l'Informatique Quantique est une nouvelle technologie passionnante à un stade précoce de développement mais c'est juste
un chapitre dans l'histoire du calcul qui remonte à des milliers d'années je pense qu'il est important de comprendre ce
contexte car cela rend ce que nous visons à faire ici un peu plus intuitif prévisible et moins
de la science-fiction depuis l'Antiquité nous les humains avons eu besoin d'effectuer des calculs ou
en d'autres termes de traiter l'information selon certaines règles et contraintes afin de permettre
la communication la construction le commerce la science et tous les autres aspects de nos vies nous nous sommes tournés vers le monde physique
pour obtenir de l'aide et grâce à des découvertes ingénieuses nous avons construit des appareils pour nous aider à calculer il y a longtemps des appareils étaient
faits de bois d'os de cordes nouées et ils stockaient l'information et facilitaient les calculs bien différemment de ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui les appareils mécaniques construits à partir de leviers d'engrenages et d'autres machines ont évolué des premières horloges astronomiques aux
calculatrices aux dispositifs informatiques sophistiqués tels que les analyseurs différentiels qui résolvaient des équations à l'aide de roues et de
disques tournants même la technologie de l'écriture a joué un rôle important dans l'histoire en permettant aux gens d'effectuer
des calculs qu'ils n'auraient pas pu faire autrement quand nous pensons aux ordinateurs aujourd'hui nous avons tendance à penser aux
ordinateurs numériques électroniques mais c'est en fait une technologie assez récente les ordinateurs numériques électroniques
ont été construits pour la première fois dans les années 1940 le premier outil connu en fait pour le calcul est l'abaque sumérien
que les experts pensent avoir été inventé à Babylone en 27 à 2300 av. J.-C. c'est vraiment
il y a très longtemps mais nous avons appris de plus en plus sur le monde naturel d'Archimède à Euclide à
Einstein nos besoins en ressources informatiques ont explosé aujourd'hui nous avons des superordinateurs qui sont
essentiellement de nombreux ordinateurs très puissants connectés en parallèle ils sont l'un des meilleurs outils que l'humanité possède pour
résoudre des problèmes difficiles mais il y a encore beaucoup de problèmes que même ces ordinateurs géants ne seront jamais capables de
résoudre plus là-dessus plus tard donc nous avons établi que les humains utilisent la physique et la nature pour nous aider à calculer
depuis des milliers d'années et pour nous aider dans notre quête sans fin de calculer plus et de plus grandes choses tu connais peut-être déjà
WEBVTT
la loi de Moore c'est en fait pas vraiment une loi c'est une observation la partie loi est un peu
ironique selon moi le nombre maximum de transistors dans un circuit intégré essentiellement une puce informatique
double environ tous les 2 ans au cours des 5 dernières décennies environ nous n'avons pas seulement observé cela mais en avons fait grand usage
avec plus de transistors nous pouvons effectuer plus de calculs plus rapides c'est essentiellement ce qui est responsable de
rendre les ordinateurs de plus en plus puissants et plus petits au fil du temps cependant il y a de mauvaises nouvelles la loi de Moore est en train de mourir
les experts ne sont pas d'accord sur quand la loi de Moore atteindra sa fin inévitable mais certains disent que c'est déjà le cas même si nous ne savons peut-être pas
exactement quand nous atteindrons notre limite nous savons que c'est inévitable car certains composants de transistors
ne peuvent pas être physiquement réduits davantage tu ne peux pas créer un transistor plus petit qu'un atome par exemple c'est
bien sûr complètement non physique cela semble stupide mais ce sont les limites avec lesquelles nous travaillons vraiment alors que
ferons-nous simplement abandonner et dire hey c'est aussi bon que possible non les humains n'ont jamais fait ça heureusement la mécanique
quantique est entrée dans la conversation la mécanique quantique a été découverte dans les années 1920 et depuis lors le monde n'a
littéralement plus jamais été le même et nous pourrions passer des heures à parler des découvertes révolutionnaires qui ont été
faites mais ce n'est pas vraiment le sujet de ce cours au lieu de cela je veux clarifier que nous savons que la mécanique
quantique et l'informatique sont déjà compatibles l'une avec l'autre les découvertes et compréhensions de la nature
que nous avons appris de la mécanique quantique ont en partie rendu nos ordinateurs modernes possibles sans la mécanique
quantique nous ne comprendrions pas ou n'aurions probablement même pas pu inventer le disque dur à l'état solide par
exemple le calcul quantique est simplement la prochaine étape naturelle dans cette évolution
mais le calcul n'existe pas dans le vide l'information nécessite un médium
calculer l'information exploite le monde physique et l'affecte également cela place des limites sur ce qui est même
physiquement possible mais comprendre la nature et les limites physiques est en fait le but de la physique en tant que
discipline donc d'une certaine façon la physique et le calcul ont toujours été entrelacés Ralph Landauer un informaticien et un
chercheur d'IBM a reconnu il y a des décennies que l'information est physique en d'autres termes l'information n'est pas une
entité abstraite mais n'existe que via une représentation physique le principe de Landauer établit une connexion
entre l'information et les lois de la thermodynamique mais en fait il y a beaucoup de connexions entre la physique et l'
informatique la physique classique était tout ce que nous pouvions explorer jusqu'à récemment mais avec la découverte de la mécanique
quantique nous sommes maintenant au bord de pouvoir créer une toute nouvelle façon de calculer et c'est formidable parce que
les ordinateurs classiques ne peuvent qu'approximer ce qui se passe réellement dans la nature et dans certains cas cette approximation est très
limitée c'est parce qu'il est vraiment très difficile d'obtenir des machines qui suivent les lois de la physique classique pour
approximer les lois de la physique quantique et la nature n'est pas classique elle est quantique une analogie qui pourrait t'aider à
comprendre est une soufflerie la dynamique des fluides est notoirement difficile à simuler et à prédire mathématiquement
même quelque chose d'aussi banal qu'une voiture se déplaçant dans du vent les constructeurs automobiles ont trouvé que c'était en fait
trop coûteux et peu pratique d'essayer de simuler cette interaction physique lors de la conception des voitures au lieu de cela ce
qu'ils ont fini par faire c'est créer un tunnel littéral qui y souffle du vent et simplement conduire une voiture dans le tunnel
et voir comment elle se comporte c'est analogue à ce que je veux dire quand je dis que les ordinateurs classiques n'approchent que pauvrement
la nature et parfois c'est trop coûteux de même leur faire tenter au lieu de simuler le vent
les chercheurs le recrée de façon similaire les ordinateurs quantiques n'ont pas à approximer les lois de la nature à un
niveau moléculaire parce qu'ils suivent ces lois intrinsèquement ils n'ont pas à simuler quoi que ce soit ils l'émulent et
les mêmes difficultés se posent quand nous simulons des batteries ou des réactions chimiques ce qui nous amène à notre prochaine
section l'Informatique Quantique à quoi ça sert alors
WEBVTT
pourquoi voudrait-on même penser à combiner la mécanique quantique et l'informatique eh bien il y a déjà beaucoup de
problèmes qui sont trop difficiles trop coûteux en calcul pour que même nos superordinateurs de pointe les résolvent
peut-être que ce sont des problèmes sur lesquels seuls les chercheurs sont vraiment concentrés mais leurs impacts pourraient toucher toutes les parties du
globe ces problèmes sur lesquels les ordinateurs classiques se bloquent sont des choses dont nous en tant que société devenons de plus en plus
dépendants de la technologie et qui nous tiennent vraiment à cœur comme l'efficacité des batteries la modélisation financière et l'
optimisation et même comment construire de meilleurs avions alors pourquoi se tourner vers les ordinateurs quantiques eh bien nous avons de très bonnes raisons
de penser qu'il y a beaucoup de potentiel ici et nous pouvons ouvrir des portes à de nouveaux calculs qui sont actuellement hors de portée même pour
les superordinateurs les plus puissants en théorie certains algorithmes quantiques offrent des avantages sur les
meilleurs algorithmes classiques possibles pour certaines applications pour d'autres applications il y a des preuves croissantes que même
avec un peu de bruit et d'imperfections les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent encore être utilisés comme outil pour se mesurer à la force brute classique
c'est essentiellement un tout nouvel outil et nous voulons découvrir encore plus de choses cool que nous pouvons en faire mais nous pouvons
aussi nous tourner vers l'idée originale de Feynman à leur sujet qui est de les utiliser pour comprendre la physique et la nature en elle-même
après tout je t'ai déjà dit que la nature est quantique et non classique et ce domaine est incroyablement riche fascinant et
interdisciplinaire il rassemble la physique l'informatique le traitement de l'information et bien sûr les domaines spécifiques des applications qui nous
intéressent cependant contrairement aux ordinateurs classiques tout le monde n'a pas un ordinateur quantique dans sa
poche jusqu'à très récemment si tu voulais expérimenter avec un ordinateur quantique tu devais en construire et entretenir
un toi-même généralement dans un triste laboratoire de sous-sol dans une université ou un centre de recherche et crois-moi je saurais ce n'est plus
le cas cependant en 2016 IBM a mis le premier processeur quantique sur le cloud il n'avait que cinq qubits à l'époque et
des taux d'erreurs assez élevés mais c'était il y a seulement 8 ans et regarde comme nous avons progressé alors où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui
il y a beaucoup de parallèles à faire avec les tout premiers jours de l'ordinateur moderne comme je l'ai mentionné c'est un très
grand défi et c'est seulement dans les 8 dernières années que les ordinateurs quantiques sont devenus largement disponibles en dehors des
personnes qui travaillent dans un laboratoire ou une installation de pointe mais dans ces huit dernières années nous avons fait des progrès sur chaque
WEBVTT
front les processeurs sont d'ordres de grandeur plus grands en nombre de qubits les gates sont bien améliorées et nous avons introduit des méthodes
pour réduire ou mitiger les erreurs intrinsèques aux systèmes quantiques même pendant que nous avançons pour créer des ordinateurs quantiques
tolérants aux fautes maintenant toi et n'importe qui d'autre pouvez utiliser l'un de ces nombreux processeurs quantiques IBM qui sont
hébergés sur le cloud dont presque tous sont les systèmes les plus récents et les meilleurs avec plus de 100
qubits mais c'est pas seulement la taille des processeurs qui est importante c'est seulement une métrique qui nous importe et
cela a du sens non si nous avons plus de qubits c'est évidemment mieux à condition que l'augmentation du nombre de qubits
ne dégrade pas les performances cependant ce n'est pas toujours le cas nous avons besoin de qubits de bonne qualité qui n'interfèrent pas
les uns avec les autres par diaphonie quand nous ne le voulons pas la façon dont les qubits sont connectés les uns aux autres est aussi quelque chose d'important à garder à l'esprit dans les
circuits supraconducteurs c'est un défi de trouver comment connecter physiquement au mieux les qubits une autre métrique hugement importante
est la fidélité de la gate à deux qubits les gates qui fonctionnent sur des qubits uniques ne sont pas aussi sujettes aux erreurs les gates à deux qubits sont bien
le plus grand domaine de préoccupation et généralement l'une des métriques de référence que nous recherchons pour voir comment les performances s'améliorent au fil
du temps les gates à deux qubits sont cruciales à bien faire car elles sont responsables de créer l'intrication entre les qubits
ce qui est l'un des phénomènes physiques qui donne aux ordinateurs quantiques leur puissance enfin nous recherchons la vitesse et l'efficacité
nous devons nous assurer que le temps passé à exécuter un programme sur la puce quantique est exécuté aussi rapidement et aussi efficacement
que possible nous appelons ces trois métriques ensemble échelle qualité et
vitesse toutes sont vitales pour améliorer les performances maintenant je veux te montrer quelques graphiques rapides pour étayer ce que j'ai dit
sur la façon dont la technologie elle-même évolue vraiment rapidement le nombre de qubits lui-même est le plus facile à
comprendre je pense et IBM a publié une feuille de route sur où nous espérons être dans les prochaines années en termes de nombre de qubits
et de taille de processeur pour 2024 quand nous filmions cette vidéo nous sommes exactement sur la bonne voie avec notre processeur Heron et Condor ensuite
la qualité ce graphique montre le taux d'erreur moyen de la gate d'intrication pour les processeurs quantiques IBM au fil du temps gardez à l'esprit
que c'est une échelle logarithmique donc même si les progrès semblent vaguement linéaires c'est en réalité bien plus rapide que cela
enfin nous avons la vitesse ce graphique montre les progrès d'une métrique que nous appelons CLOPS qui signifie les opérations de couche de circuit
par seconde essentiellement CLOPS englobe à la fois le temps nécessaire pour exécuter des circuits et le calcul classique en temps réel et
quasi-réel nécessaire fondamentalement CLOPS est une mesure de la vitesse à laquelle nos processeurs peuvent exécuter des circuits spécifiques en
série agissant comme une mesure de la vitesse holistique du système et incorporant le calcul quantique et classique
en ce moment au moment de l'enregistrement IBM est le seul fournisseur de cloud quantique qui offre l'accès à des machines de 100
qubits et plus comme je l'ai mentionné il y a quelques diapositives 100 qubits ou environ est là où la simulation classique
commence à échouer complètement donc les grandes tâches exécutées sur ces machines n'ont souvent pas d'équivalent classique ce n'est
pas possible il y a quelques nuances et quelques astuces que tu peux utiliser pour simuler certaines parties d'un circuit et d'autres
parties séparément mais en général nous savons qu'environ ce nombre est là où les ordinateurs quantiques peuvent commencer à faire des choses que les ordinateurs classiques ne peuvent tout simplement pas donc
IBM a décidé que donner accès à ces dispositifs plus grands était très important pour la communauté élargie parce que tout
ce qui est fait sur des dispositifs plus petits est simulable classiquement et donc ne peut pas mener à l'Avantage Quantique les 100 qubits
dispositifs que nous avons maintenant sont encore imparfaits et ils sont encore bruyants donc nous devons être intelligents sur la façon dont nous exécutons les tâches et
les circuits sur eux naïvement juste écrire notre circuit et appuyer sur majuscule entrée ne mènera probablement à rien
de spectaculaire mais encore une fois il y a des astuces que nous pouvons implémenter et de meilleures pratiques que nous pouvons suivre pour extraire encore
plus de performances de ces dispositifs ce qui mènera espérons-le à l'Avantage Quantique plus tôt même pendant que nous continuons
à travailler et construire nos machines tolérantes aux fautes également ce graphique montre le coût de simulation
ou le temps qu'il faut pour résoudre un problème sur les ordinateurs classiques et les ordinateurs quantiques équipés de mitigation des erreurs
et de correction des erreurs donc la ligne de calcul classique évolue de façon exponentielle à mesure que la complexité du circuit
croît pour des circuits simples ici cela ne compte pas mais c'est évidemment mauvais à mesure que la complexité croît parce que cela
rend le coût de simulation très cher très rapidement la mitigation des erreurs évolue mieux donc quand la complexité du
circuit croît c'est là où nous voulons être nous sommes actuellement ici avec les méthodes classiques et quantiques à peu près à égalité
pour certaines applications et la correction des erreurs pourrait être la plus préférable et évolue vraiment
bien nous n'y sommes tout simplement pas encore en attendant nous allons continuer à nous concentrer sur la mitigation des erreurs et à atteindre cette
zone d'utilité quantique dès que possible et en faisant usage de plusieurs schémas de mitigation des erreurs que nous allons
apprendre dans cette série nous visons à trouver des domaines d'application qui peuvent faire usage de l'utilité quantique très bientôt et c'est
vraiment le cœur de ce cours nous avons ces machines nous pensons qu'elles sont capables de faire de la recherche vraiment intéressante
alors comment les utilisons-nous dans cette dernière section de l'épisode parlons brièvement des domaines d'application pour
l'Informatique Quantique pratique il y a trois branches principales que nous pensons être les plus enthousiasmantes à explorer et à trouver des voies pour l'utilité
quantique la première est la simulation de la nature cela a à voir avec la simulation d'interactions moléculaires ou atomiques et c'est
vraiment important pour les domaines de la science des matériaux et de la chimie et pour les raisons que nous avons discutées plus tôt nous pensons que les ordinateurs
quantiques vont être bien meilleurs à cela que leurs homologues classiques ensuite il y a la recherche et l'
optimisation l'algorithme principal d'intérêt ici s'appelle QAOA un algorithme quantique-classique hybride QAOA utilise un
ordinateur classique pour entraîner et trouver des paramètres optimaux pour un circuit quantique et nous pourrons espérons-le faire cela bien
plus efficacement que l'un ou l'autre ordinateur seul enfin nous avons les mathématiques et le traitement des données structurées les ordinateurs
quantiques sont vraiment bons pour trouver une structure dans des données désordonnées où toi ou moi ou un ordinateur typique ne verrions peut-être
rien l'apprentissage automatique quantique est prometteur dans ce domaine et nous visons à l'utiliser pour des tâches telles que l'extraction de
caractéristiques et la reconnaissance de motifs c'est vraiment une période très excitante pour ceux d'entre nous qui travaillent dans le
domaine de l'Informatique Quantique pour la première fois dans l'histoire nous pouvons commencer à explorer une région du calcul qui va au-delà de
l'informatique classique ceux d'entre vous qui regardent ceci pourraient éventuellement jouer un rôle similaire à celui des premiers pionniers de
l'informatique et ils n'avaient aucune conception de ce qui allait suivre T. J. Watson d'IBM a même déclaré de façon célèbre qu'il pensait qu'il y aurait
peut-être un marché pour seulement deux ou trois ordinateurs jamais et wow avait-il tort nous
sommes tous ces premiers pionniers de l'informatique mais dans ce nouveau domaine de l'Informatique Quantique et le Quantique est souvent
mis en contraste avec l'informatique classique comme quelque chose de distinctement différent de celle-ci et souvent en concurrence avec elle mais mon
but pour cette conférence d'introduction était d'espérons-le te convaincre que d'un point de vue à vol d'oiseau nous pouvons voir l'Informatique
Quantique comme simplement le prochain chapitre dans une longue histoire du calcul c'est notre nature en tant qu'humains de chercher de nouvelles façons de
calculer et de harnacher la puissance du monde naturel et de trouver quoi en faire et nous faisons cela depuis
des siècles l'Informatique Quantique nous offre un nouvel outil dans cette entreprise et c'est à nous de découvrir comment nous pouvons exploiter
la puissance qu'elle nous offre dans la prochaine leçon de la série nous parlerons un peu plus des systèmes à 100 qubits
et donnerons un aperçu de Qiskit notre SDK logiciel quantique et comment interagir au mieux avec ces machines en ce moment merci de
regarder et on se voit la prochaine fois